hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the earthings masters the knockout
section it's daniel double versus magnus
carlsen again
uh the student uh uh faces the master
and uh yesterday was a crazy day now
magnus started with a win against dubois
then dubo had a very promising position
in game two then dubois equalized in the
match and then game four
ended in draw but now comes an even more
spectacular game than all of the games
yesterday combined this is game one of
their
their today's match and uh but i best
just show it to you
so without further ado do with the white
pieces
opens with d4 sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by magnus uh we
have c4 e6
knight to f3 and d5 the queen's gambit
declined is on the board
we have g3 preparing to fiance to the
light square bishop
and bishop to b for check now so knight
bd2 nothing out of the ordinary here
castles and now bishop to g2 by do both
we have b6 by magnus he also wants to
fianchetto his light square bishop uh
and uh here we have just
castles by do both bishop to b7 and
knight to e5 so this is all very
standard stuff and here
magnus goes uh pawn to a5 which is
not so not so common but it has been
played before we have queen to c2
dub of continuous development and now
even a4 by magnus so grabbing even more
space on the queen side
and here there is a one game in the
database where knight to d3 was played
but here uh do both plays
rook to d1 and it is as of move tended
we have a completely new game so this is
basically where our game starts
uh magnus shifts the bishop back as
there really is no point in keeping it
there anymore
bishop back to d6 and now do both trades
once uh on d5
uh captures captures so again nothing
out of the ordinary here but here comes
knight d to c4 already a first
interesting move in the game
uh dubo offers the knight but not for
free of course if the knight is captured
then bishop captures and b7 grabs the
powerful
light square bishop and after rook kicks
it back bishop goes somewhere
or you can even go knight to c6 and then
white gets uh this beautiful position
with this bishop controlling all of
these key squares
and it's going to be a very hard for
magnus to play this so of course magnus
doesn't capture the knight magnus just
continues development
with h6 preventing bishop to g5 and
now comes bishop to f4 so rook to e8
magnus again continues developing and
rook a to c1 and all of dubaf's pieces
are now
fully mobilized uh magnus still still
needs to do the same so he goes
knight to a6 uh there's there could be a
problem with the
defense of this c5 pawn so you want to
push it to c uh c7 one so we want to
push it to c5 as soon as possible
a3 by do above and now bishop back to f8
by magnus not allowing this capture
anytime soon
and now knight the e3 by do both
so what do you play here like i said
this is a very weak pawn so magnus wants
to advance it as
soon as possible we have c5 and now
comes
knight to f5 this knight eighth remove
was aimed at f5 because as
the bishop was fianchetto here you no
longer have control of the f5 square so
knight to f5
and little by little doom of species are
uh getting closer and closer to
carlson's king so
here we have c captures and b4 by magnus
and now duval
can either recapture on d4 but that
would be boring
so do both goes knight the c6 and
already here
some very interesting things start
happening so one thing magnus can do is
of course uh
just capture this but again do you want
to give up your strong light square
bishop
not so much and is this knight really
hurting anyone not really so
here magnus just goes queen to d7 now
attacks
both of the knights this now it is now
attacked twice and also
you might uh be attacking this one for
example captures here
if queen captures then you've removed
the defender of the f5 knight
so here bishop the h3 by dubois now
a lot of nasty discoveries are possible
for example knight captures an h6
check will pick up the queen uh so here
what you need to do is
either capture the knight with the
bishop or with the queen so this is what
you do here
for example queen captures and we're
gonna have a nice trade here captures
captures and captures let's say black
captures an e2
and the game continues however here
magnus said
uh okay i definitely don't want to face
knight captures an h6
check so he played king the h8 usually a
brilliant prophylactic move as
you know you don't have to worry about
any knight jumps in anytime soon
but in this case it also loses the game
so feel free to pause the video
and win this game for duba while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on beating magnus
under 20 moves uh and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight back to e5 but this come with a
deadly tempo
as it comes with an attack on the queen
and now you have to be very careful
of course not a lot of squares for your
queen
for example if you move the queen
somewhere like this then just knight
captures an f7 with
check forks the king and the queen but
you don't even have to take the queen
because it's actually a forced
checkmate in eight i'm just going to
show it because it's super fun king g8
knight captures an h6 with check you
give up this one as well
g captures and now queen to g6 with
check
only move bishop blocks and now bishop
captures on h6 threatening checkmate
here
so knight h5 only way sorry knight h5
only way to defend here
but now again bishop captures knight
captures and
knight the h6 check and that's just it
king h8 and bishop to f5
so very first and very tricky but also
beautiful now you're threatening
checkmate and if
of course the bishop is captured knight
f7 is again
a nice royal fork checkmate uh so
this is what happens after knight to e5
if you for example move the queen back
to d8 another thing you could do is
bring the queen
for example to e6 but that's just silly
bringing the queen in front of the
bishop then just
you can capture here even give up the
bishop on h3 but that's just terrible
because after queen captures
knight captures on f7 is checkmate this
knight covers the g8 square and the
queen covers the h7 square this knight
delivers check and it's just
game over so beautiful beautiful
position so here after 95 magnus said
okay i'm just gonna get rid of this
knight and he played rook captures on e5
which means he no longer has to worry
about the knight
but now dual is up material so here
bishop captures an e5 was played and now
knight to e4 so a very active square for
the knight
we have bishop captures uh on d4
grabbing that pawn and now
rook the c8 so magnus really bringing
his pieces in now he sacrificed material
and he needs something to show for it uh
queen d3
getting the queen out of harm's way and
now knight ate the c5
finally carlson brings that knight into
the game and
here we have uh queen to e3 as the queen
is under attack but the problem for dubo
is
not only uh is he in a better position
but also he's down on time duval has
some 45 seconds on the clock whereas
magnus is up
almost uh to two minutes uh so here
king the h7 by magnus again he doesn't
want to be
here maybe the g pawn will need to move
so king h7 not allowing any checks
to come through the g7 square and here
dubo just played bishop captures on c5
and when you're attacking when
a lot of your pieces are you know eyeing
at that black king
this is a very hard move to even imagine
doing because you you you want to attack
you want to
you're looking at moves like in the
knight characters here opening up an
attack towards uh
black's queen but dubois actually plays
the best move uh
suggested by the engine bishop captures
on c5
and now the problem is after carlson
plays knight captures on c5
uh now double makes a mistake uh queen
to f4 is what you need to do
as it it also frees up the e file for
this pawn
uh but duval played queen to f3 and here
he gave carlson
excellent defensive resources because
now uh the queen is aligned with
carlson's bishop so carlson played the d
for right away
as he's also getting very low on time
and now duboff's queen is under attack
so here double instead
just capture on d4 and he said okay
let's trade queens here
after all i am up material but now
magnus declines the queen trade and now
dubose queen is still under attack the
knight defends the bishop
so queen back to e3 again dubo offers a
queen trade and now queen to c6 now
magnus is threatening checkmate here
with queen to h1
so duval defends it with f3 and now
rook to e8 attacking carlson's queen a
dubose queen yet again
queen back to f2 and now it's uh very
interesting that
dubo is under 10 seconds here on the
clock and magnus goes g6 he pushes away
his knight
knights the e3 and now comes queen to f6
so magnus just making moves extremely
quickly
uh trying to put some real pressure on
duboff knight
to g4 now attacking carlson's queen and
queen to g7 so now
uh that's uh quite a bunker magnus
created there
we have rook c to d1 doubling up on the
d file and
here h5 magnus pushes back the knight
knight to e3
and now knights the b3 attacking dubose
rook
but the problem with this move is that
yes you do get
the b2 pawn however you allow the rook
to get the
d7 when the knight was on c5 that was
not possible
so dubois immediately goes uh rook uh
rook back to d3 first he uh forces the
queen to capture on b2
magnus does this and now he brings the
rook back to d7 uh
instead of going to d3 if you go rook to
d7 right away
uh it's not as strong because the queen
is now guarding the f7 pawn so you could
just meet bishop to c5 and now it's uh
it's a very tricky position to play
because if you go after the bishop for
example rook captures bishop here
then just bishop captures an e3 and you
lose the queen so
that's not possible so here first duba
played rogue back
uh and now comes queen cactus on b2 but
now it's different
after magnus grabbed the pawn because
rook to d7 now
will come with rook captures on f7 and
that comes with check
so magnus still played bishop to c5 now
threatening bishop capture 73 to win
of screen but dubo still goes for it
rook captures on f7 with
check king to h6 and now rook d to d7
a beautiful queen offering from dubo now
magnus can play just bishop captures on
e3
and he will be able to win dubof's queen
but there is only one good move in this
position actually for magnus and
it's to go back queen to h8 now to guard
the h7 square
and now uh you will be able to play this
position king to g2 then you will
capture on e3 but white will not lose
the queen
however after rook d to d7 we have queen
to
a1 checked by magnus however this is
very unfortunate as it now
loses the game because after king to g2
now you no longer have the queen and the
king on the same diagonal and this is
much less potent
so here magnus played bishop captures on
e3
but now pause the video once again uh
for the last time and
win this game for duba while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
helping dubo create this beautiful
immortal masterpiece against the world
champion magnus carlsen and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook the h7 check
very simple idea but if it works it
works king to g5 and now even the rook
captures on b7 just grabbing that uh
that material as
uh white really has no way of
black really has no way of dealing with
this queen i mean you could capture the
queen
but the then is just f4 check king to f6
and rook to f7 checkmate uh the pawn is
covering these squares the bishop
covers this square so there's no
escaping here so the queen is off limits
as
uh carlson's king will get checkmated so
after rook captures on b7
carlson plays rook to f8 he tries to
take care of the f4 square but that also
loses very quickly
the the sturdiest defense would be queen
to d4 but that also loses terribly to f4
there's just no defense against f4
for example even if you give bishop
captures g captures and queen captures
uh here white uh destroys black with
rook captures on h5
amazing stuff g captures and now rook to
g7 check
takes the king away from the defense of
the black queen king to f6
captures captures and now of course
queen and bishop will beat a rook and
knight
so here after this rook captures on b7
move uh magnus is basically without them
whatever he plays he's getting
checkmated so he tried rook to f8
uh but this just means that the e3
bishop is
unguarded so it's really amazing how
this bishop was uh
able to capture duboff's queen uh for an
entire game uh but uh you know uh
not really so here hadoop just played
queen captures on e3 with
check and it was in this position on
mov42 that magnus carlson resigned the
game
and what an amazing game by uh by a
modern mikhail tal
daniel dubov so here you resign because
any move you make is just checkmate
you can go king to f4 and then queen
rook to f4 which
makes really no sense this is just
checkmate and even if you go to f6 it
doesn't really matter
just queen the e7 is checkmate uh also
rook captures and b6's checkmate also
queen to f4 is checkmate so
a lot a lot of checkmates here so uh
not the greatest start for magnus
carlsen in um
round one of today's match but a great
start for us
the viewers as we got to experience this
beautiful masterpiece by
by by the by the doom of the the the
magician
i don't know how to call him anymore
i've tried so many great
things but he just uh you know keeps
surprising us every every game
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it hope to see uh
more brilliances from dubov in the uh
you know uh
other games but we'll see how it goes uh
i would like to thank david dawson david
kimura
uh tom nagler uh anna olila and james
and adriana harper for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day